thank you for joining us I'm faith Allen
I'm a professor of computer science the
University of Toronto and one of the
long-term visitors to the fall 2018
program on lower bounds and
computational complexity at the Simon's
Institute for those of you who were here
for the first time of watching on video
the Simon's Institute is the world's
leading venue for collaborative research
and theoretical computer science
established in 2012 with a grant from
the Simons Foundation the Institute
brings together the world's leading
researchers in theoretical computer
science related fields as well as the
next generation of outstanding young
scholars to explore deep and solve
problems about the nature and limits of
computation
today I had the pleasure of introducing
a needle Natha Swami who is the current
journalist the residents of the Simon's
Institute the journalist in residence
program was created in fall 2016 with
the goal of increasing visibility for
theoretical computer science and
supporting science journalists
interested in covering the field
presently journalists participate in the
Institute's programs and engage with
visiting scientists they also give talks
on their work and offer advice to
scientists who would like to learn to
communicate their work to the public in
the eleventh then the Swami is an
award-winning journalist his first book
the edge of physics he'll talk about
today was book voted book of the year in
2010 by physics world the second book
the man who wasn't there when a Nautilus
book award in 2015 and September he
talked about his recently published
third book through two doors at once
Neil is a former staff writer and deputy
news editor for New Scientist magazine
he's a freelance feature editor for the
Proceedings of the National Academy of
Sciences frontmatter
he's also written for nature quanta
Nautilus Discoverer magazines Neil has
been a guest editor for the science
writing program University of California
Santa Cruz and organizes and teaches an
annual science journalism workshop at
the National Center for Biological
Sciences in Bangalore India before
becoming a journalist and Neal worked as
a software engineer here in Berkeley
when I was asked to introduce this talk
in early November I decided I should
read the edge of physics I found it a
fascinating combination of travelogue
and history of mostly recent science
specifically it describes the huge
experiments the particle physicists and
cosmologists have been doing to detect
neutrinos in dark matter and the mostly
remote locations where these experiments
were being performed including Siberia
the Chilean Andes met Mauna Kea and
Hawaii
the kuru desert in South Africa
Antarctica and the Himalayas I really
enjoyed the interesting details he
mentioned such as the statue of Shiva
outside the particle accelerator at CERN
in Geneva
Shiva's dancing inside a ring of fire
scattering the darkness of illusions I
also like the stories he told about the
people involved in science for example
when Joseph Taylor won the Nobel Prize
in 1993 he invited Jocelyn Bell to join
him as his guest this was Taylor's way
of acknowledging her discovery of
pulsers for which her advisor when the
Nobel Prize in 1974 today will have a
chance to hear from O'Neill about his
experience riding the edge of physics
the challenge of combining travel and
science and the reasons why he chose
this format for the book please join me
in welcoming Anil
[Applause]
Thank You faith for that introduction
and I am really honored that you
actually read the book I must admit it's
been a long time since I've researched
and wrote the book so I had to read the
book to figure out a few things that I
had forgotten myself so so what I want
to talk about today is a little bit
about the travels that I did for writing
the edge of physics these were as fate
mentioned travels that took me to some
very remote parts of our planet Siberia
the Atacama Desert in Chile all the way
to the South Pole so and there was a
reason why I wanted to write a book
which was focused on these locations and
the main reason was really to bring
about a feeling for physics as much as I
was going to describe the science and
experiments I also wanted people to feel
a certain way about what's being done
and I felt like describing these remote
locations was going to be a way in to
you know to accomplish that task the
research for the book actually began
here in Berkeley I had just become
physics news editor back in London when
I was working for New Scientist and I
had I was visiting Berkeley and I met
Saul Perlmutter that name may be
familiar to you now because in 2011 he
won the Nobel Prize for having
discovered that the expansion of the
universe is accelerating he is a
Lawrence Berkeley National Labs
and researcher and I think he might also
be faculty here I forget but in 2004
when I met him we met at a Starbucks at
the corner of cedar and Shattuck for
those of you who know it's gone now
there's the Starbucks and he hadn't yet
won the Nobel Prize so I could actually
get to meet him in the Starbucks which
won't be possible now and I was trying
to tell him about this idea I had where
I wanted to visit mountaintops and write
about telescopes and also tried to tell
a bigger story about
the physics and it was he who planted
this idea in my head that you don't have
to restrict yourself to mountaintops
that there are other things happening in
physics which are very extreme or other
physics being done in very extreme
locations the experiments are also
extreme and that got me thinking about
where else can I go and it became a
fascinating sort of task to pick pretty
much the most extreme locations I could
find and then try and piece it together
together to see if there was a story
larger story about cosmology that could
be told about what's happening in
cosmology about what's happening in has
for particle physics and particle
physics so it was a combination of
wanting to pick really the most extreme
places possible and the most extreme
experiments possible and also trying to
find a way to assemble the jigsaw puzzle
of telling a larger story so and as part
of that even before I could complete
I know convinced a publisher to take a
punt on this I had to do these travels
because the the science and the physics
that I was going to describe was not new
so it was not like some groundbreaking
physics that I was about to you know
tell stories about in the book so this
book would have only worked if I could
write in the way that I was claiming I
was going to write it so I actually had
to do a few journeys well before I had
any guarantee from a publisher that it
was going to be published so the first
place that I went to is a place in the
Atacama Desert it's in the Chilean Andes
this was to a place called Mount Paranal
to see something called The Very Large
Telescope astronomers have some
wonderful ways of naming their
telescopes this is a telescope built by
the european southern observatory ESO
their new telescope which they're
working on now is called the extremely
large telescope and and believe it or
not they have another one in the works
which may or may not happen it's got an
acronym a nice acronym called owl for
overwhelmingly large
this one this is the first place I went
to to see ya you see these domes up
there those are four domes that which
house for 8 meter class telescopes and
together they make up what's called the
Very Large Telescope and the reason for
going here was to both write about the
construction of these amazing telescopes
but also to give readers an
understanding of why telescopes are
built in places like this so this is you
know one of the driest places on earth
it's on the leeward side of the Andes
that mountain is at about 9,000 feet the
air is extremely dry and dry air is
really good for astronomy astronomers
have a term that they call seeing so the
you know a good a place with good seeing
is essentially very very good for
astronomy because the light that's
coming in from the cosmos it doesn't get
messed up by the atmosphere so and water
vapor in the atmosphere is a big no-no
for astronomers so this because of its
dry atmosphere some places here have not
seen rain for decades and it's so dry
that NASA tests its Mars rovers here
before sending it to Mars it can find
life here to find it on Mars that's the
idea so the other reason why the Chilean
Andes are such a great place is because
of some because of a climactic condition
there's a cold current that flows along
the coast of Chile and this cold current
causes a inversion layer it basically
pulls down the cloud cover to about
7,000 feet so normally clouds that would
be at 30,000 40,000 feet are all pulled
down to about 7,000 feet around these
mountains so these mountaintops for most
of the year are about the cloud cover so
when they're looking up they're getting
about 350 days of clear skies right so
it's an extraordinary place for
astronomy and the place is littered
literally littered with telescopes
optical Astronomy radio astronomy and
and just to give you a flavor for what
they were building in the late 1990s and
early 2000s these telescopes have for
like I said eight meter class therefore
eight meter class telescope so each
telescope has a mirror that is eight
point two meters wide these where the
time and probably still are
the single largest pieces of glass that
have been used for making telescope
mirror so it starts with a blank which
is about 45 tons of glass that has been
poured in you know a blank is created
that's then ground down and even after
grinding it down to the required shape
it's about 23 tons each mirror and that
and that mirror is then being held up by
a steel truss that itself is about 10
tons and the mirrors are because they're
you know I think they're about I forget
18 inches thick which is actually quite
thin when you think of the expanse and
so as the telescope is tracking some
celestial object it's actually deforming
and in order to keep the shape precise
the mirror is resting on 150 actuators
that are constantly pushing and pulling
to maintain the curvature so in essence
the mirror is actually not anchored it's
just resting on these things and this is
a seismically active region you know
there are some major fault lines there
and they have earthquakes all the time
so how do you build something where this
massive piece of glass is just resting
on Pistons in a you know land where you
can have massive earthquakes so the
truss structure that is surrounding
these pieces of glass have clamps so the
moment there is any intimation of a
tremor these clamps reach out hold on to
the mirror and pull it off the actuators
and literally hold onto it and then the
whole mirror is now anchored to the
larger structure and it larger
structures built to sway with
earthquakes so an earthquakes have
happened all the four mirrors have been
protected this way they literally lift
23 tonnes off the base and hold it while
the earthquake is going on and then put
it back and start observing so it's
amazing so the reason I went here was to
see how these telescopes were built to
tell readers about you know the
construction of it what it takes to work
in these amazing places extremely dry
pretty hostile environment and and also
to learn about how these telescopes were
used for the discovery that I told you
about that Perlmutter had worked on and
others other teams had worked on which
was to find out that the expansion of
the universe has been recently
accelerating recently meaning in the
last four or five
billion years all notions of time and
space change when we were talking with
the cosmos recent you know four or five
billion years is recent so after I
finished with Chile I came back this
would have been I think October 25th
2005 I wrote it up and then I went to
see another experiment even before I had
a proposal ready for the book so this
was all sort of research to put together
a proposal and I wanted to see another
telescope in Siberia called the Lake
Baikal neutrino telescope neutrinos are
subatomic particles which we which were
predicted in the 1930s and were
discovered two dec two decades later so
these are not mysterious in any sense of
the word they do exist but they're
extremely hard to detect because as the
name implies neutrinos are neutral they
can go through normal matter without
interacting at all so you essentially
need very very large detector volumes in
order to find these and one way of doing
it is to look for neutrinos hitting
water molecules when neutrinos hit water
molecules they emit something called a
Cherenkov cone of light or Cherenkov
radiation which is essentially a muon
that is generated when a neutrino hits a
water molecule the muon moves faster
than the speed of light in water not
faster than the speed of light in vacuum
but faster than the speed of light in
water creating a wake so it's it's
essentially like like you would have a
sonic boom something equivalent to that
with light and it's this Cherenkov
radiation that if you can detect that's
the signature depend on me there are
other ways in which these this radiation
can be created but there are ways in
which you can figure out that this has
been created because in neutrinos
smashed into a water molecule but again
it's very very hard to detect these
neutrinos so the the grand idea that the
Russians had was to instrument a large
volume of the water of Lake Baikal now
this this Lake this Lake so when I
contacted the Russians actually I had a
German researcher was the go-between I
was told that yes you absolutely could
you can come and visit us but you have
to come in March in April March napal if
you don't know is peaks IV
winter and so I was really surprised why
are they working during the peak
Siberian winter it turns out it's it's
actually fantastic Russian ingenuity
because in order for you to build a
telescope in this case the telescope is
literally detectors that are submerged
in the water which are looking for these
flashes of blue light that happen when
neutrinos hit the water molecules yeah
if you have to do this in say oh you
know seas and oceans which have which
have been done you need ships and
submersibles and all sorts of diving
equipment and it's very very expensive
the Russians decided let's just wait for
the lake to completely freeze over and
then we just come every two months
during the peak of winter and set up our
ice camp on top of the lake they cut
holes in the ice send their divers into
the freezing waters to locate the
instrument which they have left behind
the last previous year bring it back up
and then repair it and they literally
have two months before the ice starts
melting and cracking and they have to
get out so I had to go there in the peak
of winter this was an incredible
experience for a writer and so those so
that's Lake Baikal seen from the shore
one shore the lake is about six hundred
and thirty kilometers long and it's 80
kilometers wide at its widest
it's about 1.7 kilometers deep on
average and it has 20 percent of the
world's unfrozen fresh water and 20% of
the world's unfrozen
it's a massive lake right and this thing
freezes over completely the the ice that
you're looking at here is one metre
thick during the winter so that's how
cold it is and those black dots that you
see this that's about four kilometers
away from the shore and when I got to
the ice camp that's where the
researchers were working they were
basically this is what this is the you
know the scene that greeted me now
they're basically what they're doing is
getting the instrument that they have
submerged inside the lake the what they
have done is they have submerged 228
photomultiplier tubes arranged in
strings these photomultiplier tubes are
essentially looking for these flashes of
light when neutrinos hit water molecules
convert them to electrical signals and
then send them to the shore station but
that's about one kilometer inside the
lake when they come in every winter so
they have to cut the hole in the ice
send divers in find out where the
instrument is and drag it up so what
they've dragged up here is just buoys
the actual instrument is still inside
every time I give this talk I look at
that man and wonder these are all
postdocs and PhDs by the way and he was
working so hard he was sweating in
sub-zero temperatures so this was the
second trip and to write about neutrino
physics and how neutrinos can also be
incredible cosmological signals so they
haven't found it yet but one of the
things that they're looking for is
neutrinos from the inhalation of dark
matter particles so dark matter
particles can self annihilate and one of
the byproducts of that annihilation can
be neutrinos and if you find these
signals coming from say the center of
the Milky Way or the center of the Sun
where the gravitational forces such that
dark matter which is a hypothesized
particle is accumulating in large
numbers then it can self annihilate and
you can end up with a neutrino signal
from these regions so one of the things
that they were looking for is that you
know and also neutrinos coming from the
atmosphere when cosmic rays hit the
upper atmosphere that generates
neutrinos you can look for neutrinos
from outer space from Astrophysical
events so this experiment was the first
experiment which had instrumented a
natural body of water and seen
atmospheric neutrinos and there's a lot
of details about how that's figured out
but I will move on just to give you a
flavor for the other experiments but
this was you know to give you an idea of
how frugally this was done the Russians
have been working on this and I went
they had been working on it for twenty
years and they had done all of that work
with twenty million dollars which in
today is like if you think of neutrino
experiments today even a two or three
year of effort will cost a quarter of
you know two hundred fifty million three
hundred million dollars which I'll show
you another one where that's those are
the numb
so and then I you know came back after
this experiment ended up writing a
proposal convinced the publisher that
this is something worth writing and
publishing so once I had that then I
started doing the other travels and I
still think that if a publisher had said
no or rather if no publisher had said
yes then I would still have done this
these travels they would have just taken
10 years or longer but as it happened I
had to then start doing them within two
or three years so because now there was
a deadline
and the next I made a series of trips to
see the Large Hadron Collider so and
when you're writing when when you're
writing a book which involves extreme
trouble going to Geneva from London is
the last thing you should be doing you
go to Geneva and if the bus timetable
says the bus is going to come at 1921 it
comes at 1921 there is no drama there is
nothing for a writer to worry about it
was really bad in that sense all of the
drama was happening 100 meters
underground so this chapter was written
in the form of a travel through the
tunnels of the LHC so it was not a
trouble oh about land you know with any
kind of mystery or danger
everything was inside underground so I I
got to see there let's see about three
times before it was functioning so you
actually go and you know you I stood in
exactly this location this is not a
picture I took this is one of their
stock pictures but this this is the kind
of scene like you could stand there and
look at this giant thing and I won't I
won't focus on the LHC because it's been
in the news so much and in popular
imagination it hardly counts as extreme
anymore so the other experiment that I
visited soon after that was to a dark
metal detector now dark matter is like I
said these are hypothesized particles
that we think exists because we can see
the influent the gravitational influence
of dark matter or normal matter right so
so and there are theories which kind of
tell us what
Zermatt particles this might be and
there are there are lots and lots of
experiments they've been going on for
decades now that have been trying to
look for dark matter through what I call
direct detection techniques essentially
looking for the direct impact of a Dark
Matter particle on some detector
material for instance the experiment
that I was visiting which actually
started in Berkeley and Stanford the
first version of it it's called the
cryogenic Dark Matter search and this is
essentially looking for the impact of a
Dark Matter particle on an ultra pure
crystal of germanium or silicon and the
idea would be that if the Dark Matter
particle hits the the germanium atom or
germanium or silicon atom it would
basically set the crystal lattice
vibrating raise the temperature of that
crystal by milli Kelvin or you know send
vibrations that can be detected by
superconducting pins on the surface all
of all that is great in theory but the
temperate temperature rises in milli
Kelvin and and if you try to put the
crystal lattice out on the surface of
the earth here there are other sources
of noise that will completely swamp that
signal for for instance cosmic rays or
even our radioactivity even if you are
chilled at it from all other particles
except radioactivity and you went and
stood near it your body's radioactivity
would trigger signals in that so these
detectors have to be shielded from all
possible sources of noise and what are
the places one of the obvious places to
put these detectors is deep inside mines
which which have been either abandoned
by miners or which are still functioning
mines but are available to put some
small physics experiment inside and
again I was talking to a researcher who
said I was telling him about this plan
of going to extreme places and he said
well Minnesota is not extreme but if you
really want some drama going winter so I
went to Minnesota in winter and as it
happened there was a storm heading
towards Minnesota and I spent four hours
basically outrunning the ore out driving
the storm towards northern Minnesota so
that was a little bit of drama but
that's about it
and then again everything happened as a
travel piece going down into a mine and
coming out so this was the
the the Minehead the the equipment at
the very head of the mine and you see
that cage just pay attention to the
dimensions of the cage that's the case
that takes you down half a mile
underground this would have been used by
the miners the mine itself was
functioning from 1818 80s to 1960s
before it was abandoned and and the
miners left behind all the equipment and
the physicists took over but that's
that's the cage you know but six seven
people can fit into that it's about four
feet by four feet by about ten feet and
it takes about three minutes to go into
the bowels of this mine and when you
come to the very bottom the door opens
and you see this sign level number
twenty seven two thousand three hundred
forty one feet below the surface and if
you were to turn left at this point you
will see a long tunnel it's called a
drift tunnel this is the tunnel that the
miners would have you is to bring the
ore out from inside the mountain and you
go all the way in and when we went there
our guide he basically switched off all
the lights and held up a candle to kind
of show you that this is the this is the
light with which the miners of that
worked when they were working in the
1880s early 1900s they had literally
this kind of light too and using you
know sledge hammers and drill bits and
maybe towards the end of their mining
pneumatic drills but they had they took
out something like seventeen million
tons of war from this mountain it was
the biggest iron ore mine in Minnesota
at the time if you now come back to them
to the shaft and when the door is opened
we went left and we went into these
caverns left behind by miners if you
turn right at this point you see this
this is the this is the new physics
laboratory well it's not new anymore
it's been functioning for a long time I
went there in 2007 and it had been
working you know functioning well before
that so this is what physicists
physicists have excavated so two large
caverns about forty feet high fifty feet
wide and 270 feet deep and every piece
of equipment here including that giant
thing that you see there that's a
neutrino detector which is detecting
neutrino beams that are being sent from
Fermilab in Chicago through the earth
all the way to
this underground mine that equipment is
about seven thousand thousand tons of
steel and electronics and everything
every little piece of this came down
that cage that four by four by four ten
cage including the excavator which had
to be disassembled and assembled and
underground and then start excavating
and take out all this material and then
bring in all this you know equipment so
there are two such caverns massive ones
I was there to look at these Dark Matter
detector so Dark Matter detector I
didn't get to see them because it was
completely shielded but they're
essentially crystals the size of a
hockey puck about I think six of them
going to each of these copper canisters
and there are thirty of them in total
the detectors they're all in a cryo
start the whole thing is cooled down to
40 milli Kelvin then and shielded with
polyethylene and LED then you know new
LED then all LED because new LED is
radioactive so they need all LED to
shield against a new LED I mean it goes
on and on and on until they think that
they have a detector that literally
detects nothing either either it's being
shielded from all the sources of noise
or they have managed to figure out if
there is a signal then they can explain
what the signal is you know what is
causing that signal so once they have
that set up then if you see an anomalous
event which has the right signature for
the expected Dark Matter particle then
they can claim discovery so far nothing
usually nothing like I mean this is not
the only experiment happening in
underground mines there are tens of them
all over the world and I think today
there was a news about another
experiment coming up now so there's
something about dark matter that really
is very mysterious we still haven't
figured out what these particles are if
they are particles if there is dark
matter I mean there is a lot of ifs and
buts going on here but this was for the
purposes of the book fabulous because
you could talk about dark matter you
know there's a whole narrative but how
difficult it is to do this experiment
from there I went to Mauna Kea so Mauna
Kea is another place which is like the
Andes it's again pockmarked with
telescopes there and that's where
another massive telescope is being built
so in terms of naming conventions
there's this other set of telescopes
where they're just naming it by the size
so this the
that's being built now just being called
a 30 meter telescope so evocative names
are not part of the astronomers lexicon
which is amazing given what they're
observing and what they're seeing the
telescope's are named so precisely but
anyway I was there to see the Keck
telescopes and here you can see the
inversion layer of the clouds right the
clouds are actually below the summit
this is also have the same climactic
sort of phenomenon that makes the sky
above clear for telescopes is also
happening in Hawaii around Mauna Kea
these are the two Keck telescopes these
were the first telescopes there were 10
meter class that broke the kind of
paradigm of building mirrors from a
single block of glass so by the time you
got to anything beyond 8.2 meters it
became extremely unwieldy to have a
single piece of glass for the telescope
mirror so they came up with this method
where you segmented the entire mirror so
each Tek mirror which is 110 meters in
diameter is made up of I think 36
segments so each segment is 1.8 meters
and when you think about it 1.8 meters
is itself already a huge telescope and
you put 36 of them together and then
these segments have to be very very
precisely aligned because as the
telescope is moving any even the
smallest kind of change in the curvature
can mess up your signaling or your data
collection so again there are actuators
sensing you know how these things are
moving relative to each other and
constantly pushing and pulling so in the
case of the VLT the 8 may 8 meter glass
mirror had 150 actuators that work that
was controlling the curvature of the
entire mirror here there are three
actuators per segments and each segment
is being individually controlled so the
overall curvature is exactly what you
want as the telescope is tracking some
object so and again you know this was an
amazing piece of engineering also I
think they're still until the big
telescopes come they're still the
largest telescopes around from there it
was a trip to see in this case the
telescope was actually not yet
constructed I was I wanted to write a
chapter on radio telescopes
and as it happened the Square Kilometre
Array was being planned and when I went
there were two lands on on this planet
that were had been chosen as the
possible location for this future
telescope the Square Kilometre Array
refers to a radio telescope which will
have about 3000 and tenez and the the
total collecting area of the 3,000
antennas will be one square kilometer
and it's almost impossible to visualize
sort of the size of this thing
and at the time South Africa and Western
Australia were in the running and I
chose to go to to South Africa I could
have just as well gone to Western
Australia and written the same story so
I was you know they here again was a
writer writers choice I wanted something
different than the rest of the places I
was visiting so in terms of the science
it could have just as well been Western
Australia because I was still write
writing about a possible future
telescope the telescope was not
different but the land was the history
of the land the politics all of that was
different so from a writer's perspective
it was a very deliberate choice to go to
South Africa or other than to Western
Australia and this was the land I saw it
it was it's called the kuru it is just
south of the Kalahari Desert Herod Herod
land so when I went there this is all he
was just empty land and this this was
the land where this is the place where
the heart of the Square Kilometre Array
is going to be situated so in this was
in 2007 and when I in in 2012 the
international radio astronomy community
decided to award the telescope to the -
you know the people who are going to
construct it and they decided to split
the telescope and with radio telescopes
you can do this so they gave the high
frequency part to South Africa and the
low frequency part to Western Australia
so this is the region where the high
frequency part of the radio telescope
will be sited so 3,000 antennas about
2,000 of which will be in a cluster so
those 2,000 which are going to be in a
cluster will give the telescope its
sensitivity and then there will be
antennas spread
Africa possibly spanning 3,000
kilometers and that span is going to
give the telescope its resolution
because they can then do very long
baseline interferometry and the low
frequency component so so the high
frequency will be looking for radio
waves from about 1 gigahertz up to 20
maybe even 30 gigahertz eventually and
then the low frequency component is
signals from the cosmos which are below
1 gigahertz going all the way down to
maybe 100 or 70 megahertz and that's
that's done not using these and so when
we think of radio telescopes we kind of
think of these dishes moving around in
concert you know like The Very Large
Array in New Mexico that you might have
seen the movie contact and you know
those were radio telescopes so but
actually some of the more profound work
in radio astronomy has happened because
of things called phased arrays which are
literally just television antennas stuck
in the ground in arrays and then you use
electronics to figure out how to focus
the antenna or the telescope in the sky
so that part is being built in Western
Australia and from South Africa the the
next part was positively to the most
amazing place where astronomy and
cosmology is being done which is
Antarctica I was there to witness
something called long-duration balloon
flights and this this was this was my
first sighting of Antarctica from the
from the plane the journey to get to
Antarctica itself was quite I mean not
hard but long I was in London at the
time so London to Los Angeles Los
Angeles to Oakland Oakland to
Christchurch two days of being in
Christchurch while the u.s. Antarctic
program kits you out with extreme
weather gear so I remember asking them
what should I bring for 4mm clothing and
they said please don't bring anything
you will not know you you won't have a
clue as to what to bring just come and
we kicked you out and you really have to
they give you about 30 pounds of gear
that you have to then wear as you get
onto the plane because you don't want to
land somewhere where the gear is not on
you the frightening part is you're
basically flying over the ocean so if
the if the plane crashed you're wearing
20 pounds of stuff that you can't get
out of and it's pretty much a guaranteed
watery grave I don't see the point of
that but any
they have their reasons we could not get
on to the plane without wearing all that
stuff including very heavy boots and all
sorts of stuff and this was a this was a
US military transport plane c-17 which
is massive plane meant for transporting
cargo and as passengers we are sitting
on the sides and they're just two
portals four windows in the entire plane
and you know looking out this was the
first sign you know the blue waters of
outside Antarctica the Southern Ocean
with the glaciers no the icebergs I was
there to watch the launch of instruments
like that these are basically particle
physics experiments that are being flown
to the edge of the upper stratosphere
so experiments that weigh almost two
tons that are taken up by balloons to
about 40 kilometers into the upper
stratosphere and the reason for doing
these in oh by the way that's Mount
Erebus
I think that's yeah if I'm not mistaken
that's 12,500 feet high it's the
southern most active volcano it's quite
amazing you are in Antarctica everything
is frozen there's there's ice there's
literally a glacier on the very top but
it's an active volcano so that's how
cold it is and that's how crazy that
place is so this these experiments the
reason why they're doing it in
Antarctica is because every Austral
summer in the the summer in the southern
hemisphere there's a something called
circumpolar anticyclone that sets up in
the upper atmosphere so there's a
basically a air stream that's going
counterclockwise at in the upper
stratosphere and the idea is to get a
balloon up into that air stream and then
it's just going to keep going around and
round over your head so if you try to
launch such a balloon on the continent
somewhere it will just go across the
continent and then you have a run after
it and you don't know where it'll come
down here you can just watch it going
around a couple of times and then
hopefully bring it down bring down the
payload using parachutes pretty much
where you want it to come down doesn't
work like that at all the stories about
recovering payloads are harrowing and
but nonetheless that's the reason for
doing it there and by and large they
succeed but they still have pretty
dangerous missions
to get the payload back so I was there
to watch one of these and just to give
you a sense of what it takes to launch
the balloon to give you a bit of
historical context in 1904 or 3m I'm
hazy with these numbers now these things
used to be at my fingertips at one point
but it's been 10 years but I think 1903
or 1904 Robert Falcon Scott was the
first person to rise up in a balloon
over int arctica his balloon had a
volume of about 18 no 8,000 cubic feet
it was filled with hydrogen and it was
tethered to the ground so there was a
basket in which Scott could get in or
any one person could get in and the
balloon will rise and the whole thing
rose up to a height of 800 feet right so
8,000 cubic feet of hydrogen rose to an
altitude of 800 feet this balloon from
the tip of the payload to the top of the
balloon is 1,000 feet just a balloon
right so and what's happening here is
the payload is is on a launch truck it
is connected to a parachute that's
somewhere here are the explosives and
then the balloon fabric is being filled
up with helium so and you see these
these are helium filled lines so there
are two massive and again all of this
stuff is being taken by a ship or plane
mainly by ship you know even even the
tankers with helium that is there's a
there's a truck somewhere outside here
which has helium tanks as we walk
possible
so imagine super-sized versions of that
on the ice so we're standing on the Ross
Ice Shelf here the Ross Ice Shelf is the
largest ice shelf on the planet it's
about 200 feet thick and for some reason
it's always referred to as being the
size of France I have no idea what that
means but if you know what the size of
France is the Ross Ice Shelf is the size
of France if you're from England you
call it the size of Wales I think here
is the size of Texas doesn't matter I
have no idea but it's huge and it was
interesting that when I started doing
the first few trips I had a very very
bad camera it was just a point-and-shoot
and I realized very soon that I needed
to learn a photography and get a better
camera so this by the time I got to
Antarctica I had started
figuring out how to take better pictures
so I really like this picture but this
is helium filling you know the balloon
being filled up with helium I have a
video to show you now
of the launch itself
it's a different payload
[Music]
and to give you a sense so that payload
I don't know if this one was two tons
but in general these payloads are two
tons the balloon fabric is point zero
zero zero eight inches thick like a
sandwich wrap right and despite that it
is so big that just the fabric alone
weighs something like 5500 pounds or
almost two tons and then two tons of
payload and then all the helium that has
to be put in there's about thirty-seven
million cubic feet of helium going into
that balloon which it the balloon
doesn't inflate fully because of the
temperature at sea level in Antarctica
but by the time the balloon reaches
cruising altitude at 120 thousand feet
it is 400 feet across it is so big his
heart is the size of half a full moon
and you can stand on at sea level at
McMurdo and look up and you can see the
balloon is that big right and then it
goes around for two weeks maybe three
and then the payload is brought down so
you detonate the explosive and the
payload detaches and falls free Falls
for a while the parachute opens up and
then hopefully you it falls where you
can recover it by and large they always
recovered it and the experiments that I
was looking at we're looking for at
least the way I was framing the story
for my book was the experiment was
looking for science of primordial
antimatter there's a huge question about
why there's only matter in the universe
and no antimatter because our theory is
if the symmetries of physics have to be
are correct then matter antimatter
should have been produced in equal
amounts obviously that's not happened so
this was one way in which if you could
detect primordial antimatter an anti
helium coming from somewhere in deep
space that's a very clear sign that
there are galaxies and stars that are
made of antimatter as opposed to matter
I mean the term antimatter no matter is
just terminology but something with the
opposite charge so from Antarctica then
or rather from McMurdo which is on the
coast I got to go to see the IceCube
neutrino telescope at the South Pole so
it's a three-hour flight from from
McMurdo to the South Pole in a Hercules
LC one
thirty this is a plane on skis this is
both the arrival lounge and the
departure lounge at the South Pole you
get off the plane and people are ready
to get back into the plane because the
plane the engines are not shut off you
you stop the engines for any length of
time and that's it the plane doesn't get
off the ground
the skis on which it has landed will
freeze the engines will freeze it'll
take a whole lot of energy to basically
father thing so the best way out for
them is to keep the engines running for
half an hour everybody gets out the
people who have to get back to McMurdo
get back in the cargo is unloaded
reloaded whatever and then they get off
in 30 minutes any longer than that then
they're wasting fuel so so this is
landing at the South Pole I was there to
see the building of the construction of
this thing called the IceCube neutrino
telescope so the Lake Baikal neutrino
telescope that I showed you earlier
where these photo detectors that had
been submerged into the water right the
idea is the same you're still looking
for the smashing of a neutrino against a
water molecule here the water molecule
happens to be frozen it's ice but the
sense of the argument is the same you're
instrumenting one cubic kilometer of ice
in order to see the Cherenkov radiation
that is emitted when neutrinos smash
into water molecules but how do you
instrument one cubic kilometer of ice
and these people came up and you know
rightfully or you know most of the
people are from this concent so ice
wasn't non-issue for them but again you
have to you have to drill two and a half
kilometers into the ice the ice sheet at
the South Pole is about three kilometers
thick right and you have to drill and
and that the first 1 and 1/2 kilometers
of the ice is pretty cloudy because of
dust that has settled over tens of
thousands of years you really need to
get deep into the ice sheet before the
ice becomes crystal clear and so they
literally had to use boiling hot water
at a thousand psi they're pumping hot
water into the ice boring melting a hole
about half a meter wide and the the
drill which is essentially a hose that
is spewing out hot water is melting the
ice and the drill is weighted down with
half a ton of steel so the whole thing
as the ice is melting this thing is
falling down like
plumb-bob and it goes down to and off
kilometers and it's so precise that at
the end that vertical at hole has
deviated from the vertical over two and
half kilometers by just one meter or
less than a meter right and then it
takes 24 hours for this hole to be
drilled so they're they're boiling water
here in there in there you know and then
they're pumping that water into the ice
melting a whole half a meter wide two
and a half kilometers deep it takes 24
hours to do that it takes 10 hours for
the drill equipment to be extricated
from the hole and now you have a hole
that's full of water
and but you have just one day to sort of
put your instruments in because if you
wait any longer the hole short freezes
shut right so you just have another day
to lower down these detectors and so
that's just a that's the expanse at the
South Pole so this is what they're doing
there there's a basically a Kevlar cable
two and a half kilometer long Kevlar
cable that is being fed into the hole
and every so often they're connecting
this thing called a digital optical
module which is essentially a
photomultiplier tube with it's it's a
computer in its own right each one of
them and they drilled 80 holes into the
ice and into each hole went in sixty of
this digital optical modules so there
are 4,800 of these artificial eyes that
have been used to instrument one cubic
kilometer of East Antarctic ice which is
well below the surface of the ice sheet
and when I went they were still building
it I think that finished about 59 or 60
of these holes this got completed a few
few years later and they have been
phenomenal in terms of detecting
neutrinos from outer space so you know
at atmospheric neutrinos are now just a
non-issue that you detect them
willy-nilly now so the the real treasure
is Astrophysical sources that are
spewing out very high-energy neutrinos
and they've managed to detect those
things this is the hole that's the thing
going into that the optical module going
into the hole that had been drilled and
one of the things that I was told was
don't turn your back on the hole and I
of course had no intention of doing so
but you know I just even leaning into
that the the drillers would sit in the
South Pole Station and joke about how
easy it would be to murder somebody at
the
because all you have to do is push them
into one of these souls that's it
they're gone right and then you have to
change the flight manifests so that you
can make sure that the flight manifest
shows that they have somehow flown all
the way to Christchurch that's it right
and the flight manifest can be I presume
easily manipulated or the who knows I
should be saying these things can you
edit it out when your so anyway it's
it's a it's an amazing place so then one
of the things I wanted to do in this
book well let me first talk about the
Mount Wilson Observatory this is I
wanted to do some history this is where
observational cosmology began Mount
Wilson is right next to Pasadena and
that is the 100-inch telescope that
Edwin Hubble used to figure out that our
universe is not just the Milky Way that
there are extra galactic nebula he
always used to call them extragalactic
nebulae he never called them galaxies
but that's what it that's what they are
they're galaxies beyond the Milky Way so
he figured out not only that the
universe was more than the Milky Way but
that that these galaxies are receding
from from us in a very with a very
linear relationship called the Hubble
distance velocity relationship and and
it was our first indication that if you
work backward in time all of these
things would have in one place it was
the first indication of observational
indication that the universe had began
in a Big Bang and then that's when so
one can say that this is where
observational cosmology began this was
built by George Hale the astronomer
George Ellery Hale in the early 1900s
and now it's still functional but you
know things have changed around LA the
in terms of light pollution but it's not
really the telescope that it used to be
so one of the things I wanted to do in
this book was as a metaphor I wanted to
visit a couple of monasteries so not
really conflate the two I didn't want to
make any connections per se between what
monks are doing and what astronomers are
doing I just wanted to make a
metaphorical connection to give people a
sense of what the astronomers are doing
by talking about what the monks are
doing so I thought let me visit a couple
of monasteries and as it happened
there's a camel dollies monastery just
further north from Pasadena if you just
drive up Highway one a lot it's
somewhere near Big Sur there's this
monastery where you go and you're
completely silent and so I was trying to
write about being in such a place to
give a sense for what Mount Wilson might
have been way back in the early 1900's
and and you can't talk to anyone there
except at the reception where there's a
monk and you can go and talk to the monk
for whatever reason you might need to
and here I was trying to figure out how
to find some connections between what I
had just visited which was Mount Wilson
and you know monks and I was telling
this astronomer I mean this monk about
my journey so far about having just come
from Mount Wilson and he started smiling
he says you know George Hale built the
observatory there yesterday I know that
and then he said my my name is father
Robert father Robert Hill it turns out
that father Robert Hale and George Hale
are descended from the same guys Thomas
Hale who left England in the 1600s came
to America so here I was trying to find
metaphorical connections and there was
an actual lineage connecting one monk to
an astronomer so for a writer this is
gold right you don't have to work at all
you just have to describe what you're
observing and your task is done let the
readers make up their minds whether
there are connections but you just
describe what you're encountering and it
was fabulous so this is just a scene of
a woodpecker outside my silent dorm
window the last journey was to a place
called
hung lay in Ladakh in in the Himalayas
so this is place in the Himalayas beyond
the 8000 meter peaks so this is the
telescope the telescope itself is rather
rudimentary at this stage I again in
terms of seeking a metaphor it was
really all I had to do was describe what
I was seeing because I was just driving
a telescope and right across is a 400
year old Buddhist monastery right so
again no effort they're actually trying
to make any obvious connections you're
just describing as a person that's
observing something and the writing does
there's job of creating connections in
readers minds if they are predisposed to
it if not it's a innocuous comment right
so it's actually worked out really
nicely so let me now how are we doing
for trying so I'll try to quickly
you through some of the those were the
sets of travels that I did
now that the act of putting together the
book started so I mean I was writing as
I was traveling but these are all
disparate chapters now I have to figure
out what was the overarching theme that
the book was going to be dealing with
and the obvious thing at that time was
that and even it's true even now there's
just that the numbers have changed but
we think that about 3/4 of the universe
is made of something called dark energy
which is the the energy of the vacuum of
space-time itself this is supposed to be
the thing that's causing the
acceleration of the or the expansion of
the universe to accelerate in recent
times quarter of it is supposed to be
dark matter which we can detect its
gravitational influence on normal matter
but we don't know what it is and then
you know the rest of physics particle
physics that we have describes normal
matter which is about four percent again
these numbers have changed since I wrote
the book so so basically I had to
identify the big questions that the book
would answer so the nature of dark
matter the nature of dark energy the
origin of mass this remember this was
before the discovery of the Higgs boson
so the book could actually take on this
question of the discover you know the
the quest to find the Higgs which is
basically the story of the origin of
mass the question of the
matter-antimatter asymmetry which is
still unresolved questions about are
there other universes are there this
leads you into discussions about string
theory about other ways where
multiverses pop up into the discussion
in physics again I was pretty agnostic
about taking a position on this this
were just ways in which you could bring
in current thinking about what's
happening in cosmology and then the big
question for physics today is
reconciling general relativity with
quantum mechanics so how could these
experiments shed light on this
unification so these were the big
questions that I set it up in the
beginning of the book and then you have
to kind of start thinking about how to
place all the all the chapters because
science books most popular science books
have one thing going for them that is
they have a very self-evident narrative
which is just the accumulation of
knowledge there is something about
writing a science book that has a linear
timeline that works really well because
you can just use the progression of
knowledge as a way to drive the
narrative
right so the mysteries are mounting
Solutions come about new mysteries
happen and you go on and on and and
that's that works really well and it's
it's pretty much the standard way of
writing a science narrative but this was
complicated because each except for the
first chapter which was historical every
other chapter is about physics that is
happening right now every other chapter
the physics was just as current like the
physics in chapter 2 the particle
physics was just as sort of developed in
terms of complexity as the physics
required for chapter 9 in about the
Large Hadron Collider so this was a
challenge having to just introduce the
right amount of physics at each each in
each chapter so that the complexity is
building up over time but yet when you
need some physics to explain say the
Dark Matter experiment in chapter 2 you
still are able to do it so that was a
problem and so the lord of effort went
into trying to structure the book where
the structure was not obvious the each
chapter had its own narrative structure
which was the travel that was easy
the larger narrative of you know how the
science is flowing through the course of
the book was the harder part and of
course I could not present the travel in
the way in the same sequence as I did
the travels because that also have to be
juggled and you have to do it seamlessly
where you don't you're not lying but you
also don't what you don't want to say
something there's obviously fall so it's
all in the ambiguity so as you write and
then you know the the book I remember in
the first couple of drafts I even I as
the writer was getting claustrophobic
reading my own work because there was
too much dark energy dark matter doc you
know every chapter was worth that so
somehow I had to find ways of getting
out of that and that worked in the third
draft I could figure out a way of
breathing again then of course
structuring the individual chapters
there was a big question of how do you
get all the theory into this in the
first draft I did this rather kind of
easy thing which is write nine chapters
based on my travel and then wrote a
final chapter about all the Theory
lumped all the theory in the very end
and said okay done
I sent the draft to my editor and she
liked all of the nine chapters and the
the last chapter she has put one big red
mark around it and saying what have you
done I mean how can you put all this
stuff at the very end as
the reader would want to read this now
so she basically said look take it out
you know take the entire chapter out and
figure out a way to move all that theory
into the first nine chapters so as it
happened as I started doing it I
realized I needed one more chapter which
could not be a Travel chapter because it
was about satellite missions so I wrote
about plank which is a cosmic microwave
background detector and used that for
some tying up some loose ends about the
theory but much of the theory that I had
just put into one chapter had to be
dismantled and sprinkled throughout the
earlier chapters and then as a writer
you're also thinking all the time about
how to take the reader from paragraph to
paragraph from section to section from
chapter to chapter have a lot of this
effort is about crafting transitions so
the last chapter of a section last
paragraph of a section connects somehow
to the first paragraph of the next
section the last paragraph of a chapter
somehow connects to the first paragraph
of the next chapter things like that you
have to think about all these things so
I just wanted to give you a sense of
what it takes so for instance in the
first chapter which is about the Mount
Wilson Observatory it starts by
describing Hubble's work all of that
sets up the history and then now I have
to transition to talking about the
monastery why would you suddenly start
speaking about a monastery right so you
have to give a rationale to the reader
what the reader should be convinced that
this belongs in the chapter so this was
the transition paragraph right so I this
is what I wrote the Greater Los Angeles
area which Mount Wilson overlooks is
hardly the quiet unpopulated unpolluted
region that Hale once found so appealing
however there is a section of
California's coastline that still
remains pristine providing a glimpse of
what Hale might have encountered these
are the forested slopes of the rugged
Santa Lucia Mountains covered halfway
between Pasadena and San Francisco
I mean amid the slopes is a camel Dali's
monastery where solitude and silence are
a way of life much as Hale desired for
his astronomers so this is a
transitional paragraph where you have
elements of something that has happened
before elements are what's going to come
and now you're telling the reader that
okay we're now and we talk about
something else but here's you're
transitioning through this right also
you have to think about chapter openings
and chapter endings so this is a scene
from the kuru the South African land
where I went to see where the talus
might be built and this was the opening
paragraph right you're just setting up a
mood just south of the Kalahari Desert
is a region of South Africa with no
physical feature proclaims it's past to
grandly you have to be a geologist to
look beyond the unrelenting Baroness
this is a land so arid that cheap
farmers need hectares of grazing land
for a single animal the khoi's aren't
people of south southern Africa call it
the kuru the land of thirst a few
hundred million years ago it was
anything but the shards of shale
underfoot speak to a time when this land
was at the heart of the supercontinent
gondwana much of which was covered by a
vast ice sheet and then it progresses to
describing the land and why the
telescope weights such a great piece of
land for building the radio telescope
and so on right and this reference to
the ice sheet it was important because
I'll now show you the paragraph that
this chapter ends the whole chapter
spends time talking about radio
astronomy and the land where it's going
to be built and then it ends with a
reference to the next chapter right
the Carew promises to be a significant
part of cosmology is evolving story but
there is another land far bigger than
the kuru that is already writing its own
narrative about 50 million years after
Africa split off and drifted northward
from Gondwana another bit drifted south
and ended up at the bottom of the world
a land more pristine than the kuru
Antarctica is fast becoming our most
sought-after window on the cosmos though
it remains as dangerous for the
untrained traveler as when humans first
started exploring it a century ago it
was with great anticipation that I set
off for the frozen continent cosmology
is biggest and boldest bet yet so this
is a transition you're basically telling
the reader hopefully have interested the
reader enough to turn the page that's
all you want them to do and this isn't
article this was one of the first things
I saw there this is a glacier that has
descended from Mount Erebus and and this
is the Ross Ice Shelf in the foreground
and that that's a section of a glacier
that you're seeing Antarctica was really
hard to write about I struggled for a
long time about how to open the open the
chapter because there's nothing in my
immediate experience experience that was
allowing me to connect with my readers
and you know most readers also will not
have any way of connecting with what
Antarctica might be as it happened I
found somebody else as writers you're
always looking for things that others
have said
which might help you in you know how you
write and I did find something that was
perfect it basically was making the
point that Antarctica is impossible to
write about but done very poetically so
I just took that right this is the
opening paragraph of the chapter on
Antarctica before I set out for
Antarctica I kept hearing expressions
like see you on the ice and so how long
will you be on the ice the ice I
realized was an insider's turn a tacit
acknowledgement of our inability to
describe Antarctica in anything but the
most mundane language Francis preferred
claims in the introduction to his
anthology of writings about the frozen
frontier nowhere else on earth is it so
clear that a place has an integrity
apart from what we might say about it
nowhere are words obviously ineffectual
a response to what just massively exists
whole and complete and in no real need
of translation that allowed me to then
start saying something about it but you
know it was a way of getting away from
this problem of not knowing how to say
something about it again I think we're
running out of time so I'm going to skip
this the other thing that happens as a
reporter
somebody will asking me whether I was a
journalist or a science writer I'm
really a journalist so I'm reporting
listening to what others are saying and
sometimes our sources say the most
amazing things and this is how the
chapter on Antarctica ends in the words
of a glaciologist who has spent way more
time than I'll ever get to spend on
Antarctica
he said not NASA glaciologists Robert
bin Chandra spoke of the absolute
stillness he felt in Antarctica the
absence of anything familiar you are
there in the middle of nature and nature
is expressed in very simple impressive
and intensive terms you can't ignore the
temperature because it is cold when the
wind blows you can't ignore the wind
because it dominates your awareness and
the surface that you're standing on and
walking across and living on that's all
there is
it's omnipresent and it's overwhelming
there is no other distraction I feel I
can't avoid this show of our place in
nature and our uniqueness and smallness
but sometimes there are people this is
verbatim this is how we spoke so you
know it's again for a writer is
absolutely phenomenal to find things
like that I will skip this and just show
you so this is the ending
so this was the monastery from the from
the telescope up in the Himalayas this
is hardly that's the Buddhist monastery
and my last you know I had to I had to
end the whole thing with a point I
wanted to make throughout the book there
is this reinforcing of the idea of
stillness and I'm I mean that in many
different ways throughout the book and
it's of particular relevance to physics
experiments there needs to be a certain
kind of quietness whether it's quietness
from radio noise for optical you know
pollution all sorts so essentially
everything that is happening in extreme
physics requires bringing the noise
boundary down down down right your so so
there is this overarching theme of
silence and stillness and then the
monasteries and they talk about the
monks are kind of reinforcing that
metaphorically and I wanted to end with
that the whole book with that message
right so this is how it ends I became
aware of the deep silence enveloping me
the monk so I'm standing right now on
the telescope 14,000 feet up in the
Himalayas looking at the monastery and
that's that's the last paragraph I
became aware of the deep silence and
whipping me the monks had built their
monastery here for a reason
now the astronomers were taking
advantage of the intense quiet to find
answers to profound questions it was
abundantly clear standing in Hanalei as
it had been in places like the South
Pole Lake Baikal Paranal and the carew
that the natural calm of these places is
what makes them ideal for cosmology we
need to protect them just as we protect
our inner peace as individuals if we
pollute them we will destroy our best
chance of deciphering our own beginnings
of understanding ourselves I will end
with that so that's the book thank you
very much
[Applause]
time for a few questions I'm curious
about two things first how did the
funding for this travel work did the
household no publishers unfortunately
don't give you money for travel I wish
they did so the way it worked the first
two trips I did on my own money I had to
there's no way out
so the chile and the Siberia trips came
out of my pocket I mean everything came
out of my pocket help but what happened
was once I wrote the proposal and got a
publisher interest they just give you an
advance to write a book they are not
concerned whether you spend it on food
or whether you spend it on travel it's
just so I had some advance so I started
using that once for the rest of the
traveling and the only place where I had
funding which could not have been done
without the funding was the trip to
Antarctica so there is a program called
artists and writers in Antarctica which
is run by the NSF you can apply and if
you're selected then you're in really
good hands because they will then
basically take care of your entire trip
so I was taken from London all the way
to the South Pole and back and on you
know the u.s. Antarctic program took
care of that so that so that would be a
major part of the funding for that trip
but the rest of it was yeah from the
advance and from my own pocket not one
more question I imagine you must have
had like hundreds of pages of notes
about your travels so how did you
organize these and like say the last
thing I am know this was I'm pretty
primitive I just open a folder first in
my desktop saying you know edge of
reason or whatever that you know working
title was and then subfolders and just
start dumping files with the intention
of looking at them later and I have the
time I never look at them it's just that
it's just that you're reading so much as
you're going along there are hundreds
and hundreds of files not just that the
transcription of my interviews if I just
printed out what I had trans there would
be stacks of paper that high right you
know you have to turn that into a book
300 pages long um I'm not organized in
any
sophisticated sense it's just literally
just folders in my computer where I'm
putting in stuff and I'm hoping that I
know where to look
it works out but there are other ways in
which you can do this there are much
better techniques out there to organize
your material I thought I would improve
with the next books I haven't even the
last book I did exactly the same thing
so something wrong with me there so for
me there were two things right I wanted
to hopefully not leave any reader behind
that's always a task that you have but I
also did not want to shortchange the
physics right the science so it's a
balancing act there are times when you
have to you know walk a very fine line
but I really never wanted to write about
the science in a way that feels like
you're talking down to your reader you
cannot do that I mean you should not do
that you can do that but you should not
do that and ya know it's a challenge and
that's something that you learn with it
comes with practice it's very easy to do
videos with just being familiar with
nature in some sense of the world also
being familiar with this amazing
technology that you talked about that is
that and maybe the dangers of getting it
how would you like to see me a story
about intellectual discoveries like
things happening in a budget of a like
the fact that you can use our programs
to do cryptography electronic commerce
so how do you do a particular gesture
like I first see that would be it would
be a different kind of book imagination
and motivation of the reader to get
their attention maybe we need the Sun
assist
there's always this attempt to try and
connect it to so if you're talking of
cryptography there's obvious connections
to what's happening you know with the
internet and but that's a very small
part of the storytelling I don't think
that really is the reason why people so
there are books where people will read
it because of its intellectual content
so so if it can be still written in a
way where the intellectual arguments are
driving the narrative so it will be in
the art of writing it it's it's it's
you're right that there are no obvious
ways in which you can connect it to
people's lives or you know create this
kind of grandeur with talking about the
South Pole but I think there are there
are books where I mean there are books
about for instance you know the debate
over the nature of free will now that's
a purely intellectual argument but it
appeals to people so there are there are
people and there are books that can be
about purely intellectual argument they
they are more difficult to write and I
as a writer would also look for the
motivations of the researchers the
researchers themselves can become part
of the story more than maybe they are in
my you know this inertia here it's the
instruments and the people building the
instruments but you know it's not
totally obvious but how you know what to
answer what answer to give you at this
point without knowing the background of
the researchers who are doing it the
background of the field itself but there
are books that have been done like that
so
the mind of a person yeah they are there
they're fascinating and there are books
that work beautifully when only focusing
on that too
Oh so how many had back you think every
background inside I mean we may give
targeting um the idea was to target
anyone who would be interested in you
know following along on this journey
high school I would imagine a little bit
yeah I mean there are things there in
the book where you always have to write
it in a way where if the person is
unable to grasps the full import of
what's being said it's at least written
in a way where they can get the gist of
it and still move on and not feel like
oh I can't go on any further right so a
lot of idioms is the trick of how you
write these complicated pieces so that
was just a list for telling you about
what the book is about
that's not how it's written so if you
read no no no I don't just start with
the list of big questions in the book
right the book literally starts with me
sitting with Saul Perlmutter in a
Berkeley cafe it's a it's a people story
I'm just talking to him and the story is
emerging so through the writing yeah
through the writing you mean there are I
mean there's so many historical things
you can given the act of you even the
discovery of dark matter itself it's
just a story it's about people pointing
telescopes and calculating velocities
and you know so it you just keep
building up the arguments and certainly
you are a dark matter and you haven't
realized that you arrived at that
conclusion yeah
okay please join me in thanking you
again